50 seconds vehicle velocity approximate
2012 per hour at an altitude of puns
magenta
nejireme and model what did it into
pokeo mission all systems nominal
expecting stage 1 ignition notified 22nd
TV kid nominal attitude nominal
states are of TVA initialize pressure
nominal affecting stage 1 ignition and
effectively by second jet cover jettison
state do burnouts stage 1 ignition state
0 separation vehicle ask use nominal
power plus the nominal stage ones burn
will last approximately 70 seconds
double sitting and in avionics current
he took 100 seconds vehicle offseason
suckling 5000rs at an altitude of
bustling 50 miles
avionics senses temperatures nominal
stage 1 TV 8 system operating as
expected maintain novel musical attitude
minutes this video studio mission
avionics power button stable vehicle has
phenomenal power bus is nominal
at
attitude Donald CBG operation remains
novel did it go how to remains a little
power button strong
attitude nominal
plus 150 seconds beautiful velocity
blackberry 95 hundred miles per hour
adele super-clean hundred mile 15 stage
2 ignition is less than 15 seconds
followed by during separation test to
complete
take a look burnout